on va maintenant jeter un coup d'oeil à
ce qui s'est passé en amérique latine
vous le savez très durement frappée par
le coroner virus 10 millions de cas en
amérique latine seulement un tiers des
décès dans le monde et martin movie you
qui est un peu notre expert crime
organisé latino américains en résidence
vous nous faites un bilan de ce qui
s'est passé dans la criminalité
pendant la pandémie il faut dire mali
mode quel élu criminels et terroristes
qui sévissent en amérique latine au tout
début on était surpris par ce qui est
arrivé plus de ruth confinement
difficultés pour s'approprier ou pour
s'approvisionner des produits chimiques
pour la production de cocaïne par
exemple et pas beaucoup de mobilité pour
envoyer de la drogue
par contre ces organisations criminelles
c'est son gré ce site très rapidement
leur ai dit que pendant la pandémie
ils sont fait des affaires en or par
exemple on voit ces images un peu
effrayante
qu'est ce qu'on voit exactement c'est
une milice pro dit que c'est les forces
spéciales du cartel des rallyes sco
nouvelle génération une organisation
criminelle qui est basse et dans les
centres l'ouest du mexique car alice co
qui contrôle tout les commerces d'un
dock sur le pacifique que ce soit au
mexique dans le reste des pays latino
américaine aux états unis voire même au
canada une organisation qui a beaucoup
grandi qui a profité de la guerre de
l'état mexicain contre les autres
cartels et qui montre aujourd'hui une
force unique au président du jamais vu
clair me rendrait presque une armée
c'est une armée et 6 qui a surpris
beaucoup tant les états unis que les
autres pays du monde de basket contre à
l'image qu'on se fait c'est des
narcotrafiquants très discret séquelles
et dont on ne connaissait pas souvent
les visages que j'étais là lâche qu'on
voit une organisation dans la quête des
sommes disciplinés avec des uniformes
qui portent des armes s'est montrée en
disant on est prêt à combattre même les
sépare
ces images semblent montrer la
solidarité et l'entrée dans temps crise
elles ont été tournées au centre du
mexique et on peut y voir des hommes qui
se promène dans des petits villages et
dans des grandes villes pour donner aux
habitants de la nourriture et des
produits de première nécessité en fait
ces images sont de la propagande et
elles ont été tournés et diffusés par le
cartel d'euralis cros nouvelle
génération juste au moment où la
pandémie frappe est fortement les
mexicains le senior man show monsieur
même show est loin d'être un
philanthrope qui partage sa richesse
il est le chef du cartel de rallye sco
qui cherche constamment à gagner des
appuis populaires et à démontrer qu'il
est le vrai pouvoir dans les régions où
il a de la fluence sont l'organisation
criminelle a bien profité de la pandémie
pour faire croître le nombre de
criminels armés
prendre le contrôle de plusieurs régions
du pays et augmenter son influence sur
la population
le cartel de jalisco nouvelle génération
est aujourd'hui le plus important et le
plus puissant du mexique
il est aussi considéré comme l'une des
trois organisations criminelles les plus
dangereuses du monde
selon les autorités mexicaines et
américaines ce cartel a des alliés et de
l' influence criminels dans plusieurs
pays dont le canada et les états unis à
cause de ses activités la cocaïne la
marijuana et les drogues synthétiques
parcourent des milliers de kilomètres
sur la côte du pacifique et sur la
frontière canado américaine pour arriver
dans les rues du canada
les activités apparemment altruiste du
cartel rallye sco nouvelle génération
font partie d'un scénario bien connu
la méthode a été mise en place par les
anciens cartel de la drogue de
l'amérique latine le rôle au capreau
pandémie est elle la pandémie a créé les
conditions pour que certaines
entreprises et personnes se laissent
éblouir par la présumée générosité et
des criminels mais on verra les
conséquences dans l'avenir psychose
collective ayant comme c'est déjà arrivé
auparavant
les criminels vont leur demander de les
avertir quand la police arrive de leur
permettre d'utiliser leurs noms et leurs
comptes pour transférer et blanchir de
l'argent et même pour cacher des
personnes andré gimenez c'est un
consultant international spécialisé dans
la lutte contre le blanchiment d'argent
est apolitique a consisté qui est ancien
procureur en colombie il connaît aussi
très bien le crime organisé de la région
point de presse
quand les gens permettent que leur
entreprise soit sauvé par ses présumés
ange gardien ils doivent aussi assumer
les conséquences
parce que ce n'est pas gratuit les
criminels vont utiliser ces compagnies
sont au nom d'autres personnes pour
transférer leur argent
c'est l'ambition et non pas des bonnes
actions la caractéristique principale
des organisations criminelles
ces images tournées par des caméras de
surveillance montrent bien que ces
bandits ne recule devant rien caché dans
un camion des assassins du cartel de
jalisco bloquent la route à la voiture
du secrétaire de la sécurité de la ville
de mexico et ils essaient de le tuer
trois personnes deux gardes du corps et
une civils ont été tués les homards
garcia le secrétaire de la sécurité
quelques blessés a survécu à l'attentât
après l'attentât les autorités ont
arrêté une partie des présumés tueurs et
elles ont confirmé que les criminels
étaient très bien armés
la pandémie a permis au cartel de rallye
sco de devenir plus puissant et plus
actifs c'est aussi à cause de ça qu'il
est devenu une cible pour le
gouvernement américain qui offre
maintenant 10 millions de dollars pour
la tête de monsieur man show le chef de
cette organisation criminelle
mais le men show n'a pas montré son
visage depuis longtemps on dit qu'il est
presque fantôme martin expliquez nous
comment dans les pays comme le honduras
le guatemala salvador
li gang de rue qui sont vraiment très
présentes dans ces pays-là 90 mille
membres de gagne criminels seulement
dans ces pays
comment ils ont pris un peu le contrôle
la pandémie de leurs pays respectifs
au tout début on croyait que ces groupes
criminels étaient bien contrôlés
si on croit les images que les temps
plein des voix le salvador où les
gouvernements avaient même mis ensemble
les leaders des séguin qui sont dessinés
me jurez qui centrait tous facilement
n'importe où d'un monde et ont croisé
comme disaient les états que les marins
ne reviendrai plus en force malgré tout
ce qui est arrivé croyez le ou pas c'est
que les marins ont contrôlé au salvador
au honduras et au guatemala
toutes les mesures sanitaires pour
empêcher la propagation de la coved
business et sont empêchés de couvre-feu
ils sont tabassés des gens voire même
tuer des gens qui n'ont pas respecté
l'ordre de rester à la maison
mais ils n'ont pas fait ça pour les
banques au pas grandeur d'âme parce
qu'ils pensaient cette business
effectivement c'est parce que les gars
des vues en amérique centrale vivent de
l'extorsion de l'extorsion qu'elles font
que ce soit aux commerçants ou à des
gens qui reçoivent de l'argent qui vient
de l'étranger donc plus longtemps les
confirmands duré moins de possibilité de
demander d'argent à ces gens là donc ils
sont comprises rapidement ces
organisations criminelles qu'il fallait
que les confirmands soit de courte durée
pour que ces commerçants continuent à
payer ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
que ces groupes sont revenus en force
martin là vous nous amenez en colombie
où les organisations criminelles
s'activent dans un autre secteur qui est
l'exploitation d'or
évidemment la vente illégale ce métal
précieux
on va regarder ce que vous nous avez
préparé les criminels colombier ont
profité de la pandémie pour semer le
chaos et la violence
des dizaines de personnes ont été
assassinées ces derniers mois dans
plusieurs endroits du pays
cependant les narcotrafiquants et les
terroristes ont concentré leurs efforts
sur l'exploitation illégale et l'achat
de grandes quantités d'or selon des
sources à l'intérieur de ces groupes le
crime organisé utilisent ces jours-ci ce
métal précieux
tout comme les armes comme monnaie d
échange à l'heure de faire des affaires
en plus ils font pression sur certains
commerçants et certaines compagnies pour
légaliser leur production et leurs
transactions en norme donne est en crise
quand les actifs perdre rapidement de la
valeur
l'or devient un investissement sûr pour
tout le monde pour les investisseurs et
les états sans doute mais aussi pour les
criminels au festival l'objectif du
crime organisé avec ces transactions
serait alors de garantir leur profit
investir l'argent en liquide et
conserver la valeur de leurs actifs et
escape ne nous oubliez les organisations
artistiques al coutelis enregistrement
financier ne peut pas oublier que les
organisations criminelles sont très
sophistiquée qu'elle utilise des
stratagèmes très élaborés et qu'elles
ont souvent l'appui et les conseils
d'avocats et de banquiers expérimentés
et des bus can au coverflow lots
et comme en commission quelle valeur
c'est pour ça que pendant la pandémie
elles vont acheter de l'or pour ne pas
subir de pertes économiques comme les
bourses
la valeur des entreprises et le secteur
immobilier peuvent s'effondrer
c'est l'or qui leur permet de garder la
richesse grâce à certains pays qui
ferment les yeux et qui ne pose pas trop
de questions les prix élevés de l'or sur
les marchés régulier encourage le crime
organisé a entreposé des lingots de ce
métal pour les commercialiser
après la pandémie ces organisations sont
convaincus que ce n'est pas facile de
suivre la trace des producteurs ni des
acheteurs on parle d'une possibilité
presque parfaite de réinjecter dans
l'économie leurs profits illégaux pour
rendre propre leur argent sale
donc la crise économique mondiale pas
tant que ça a affecté les organisations
criminelles d'après votre partage nos
six organisations criminelles ont
profité de pandémie pour accroître les
gains pour obtenir plus d'argent et pour
grandir au niveau militaire haut niveau
qui dit me mêle et bien sûr dans les
blanchiment d'argent
ce qui fait dire la plus chère
gouvernement mais aussi un spécialiste
de la lutte contre le blanchiment
d'argent et les climats organes et c'est
qu'il faudrait se poser des questions
quand et comment c'est sur l'initiation
vont faire couler tout cet argent pour
les blanchir dans les marchés légaux qui
on connaît l'autre phénomène sur lequel
vous gardez un oeil en colombie
martin c'est la présence inquiétante la
enron d'état qui est une mafia italienne
qui à part en colombie la mafia
calabraise est déjà présente le mérite
latine depuis des années donc il
achetait de la drogue au cartel déjà
présents mais il ya quelque chose de
nouveau mais ce qui est nouveau c'est
qu'il l'a droguée taxer les antennes des
filles c'est ça faire directement
on sait aujourd'hui après une opération
qui était menée en colombie par les
autorités locales et la dea américaine
c'est la dure à gan france m'a
administré comme la police en titre avec
des états unis ils sont venus me suis
arrêté six personnes qui travaillaient
directement pour cette mafia italienne
est ce que je suis aujourd'hui c'est que
l'une des grandes patronnes de la drogue
et à celles venues en amérique latine
pour organiser les sans voix pour former
ses réseaux et surtout pour diriger
directement la voix d europe
il avait un très très gros cool en
marche on avait déjà envoyé à l'amérique
du nord puis en europe 20 tonnes de
cocaïne et les retraités prévoyez qu'il
y a
et au moins 31 des tang qui devait
sortir des pays latino-américains vers
ces marchés nord-américains et européens
dans les prochains mois alors qu'on sait
que le prix de la cocaïne mondialement
est en forte hausse d'où l'intérêt pour
des mafieux comme un drogué tas de
prendre des assises la colombie
effectivement merci martin marché